[Music]
assalamu alaikum today we're going to be
responding to
joe rogan and richard dawkins talking
about how islam and religion is dying
and atheism is taking over the world
is there any evidence that that is
reaching the muslim world as well
and that people are well as i was saying
um uh
the the the downloads of of
my books have been encouraging we have
this thing called cfi has a thing called
the translation project
so in this clip dawkins says religion's
dying
as a general point would you agree with
that well
first of all we'd have to be very clear
about how we define religion
okay in terms of atheism actually
becoming more popular
or the kind of atheism which richard
dawkins himself espouses
as i mentioned in my book which is free
to download the book is called the
scientific deception of the new atheists
that's a very subtle plugin yes yes you
can put it you can see in the
description box
but i've referenced in that book it's
very small very very small booklet
really
that you can download free of charge um
all of the demographic data indicates
that most people in the west
according to pew research 90 percent of
people still believe in a higher power
according to linda woodhead only 5.5
of people believe in the strident
atheism that richard dawkins believes
in which is actually quite interestingly
from a british perspective
the same number of people amount of
people that are muslim in this country
so there's about the same amount of
muslims in this country as there are
atheists yeah strengthen atheists of
richard dawkins kind so here dawkins
he's basically saying look guys
i can tell you atheism is rising in the
muslim world
and islam is dying because people are
downloading my book
a really rigorous scientific argument
isn't it
well it's methodologically flawed from a
demographic and sociological perspective
not least because the religious
switching
cannot and has not been sociologically
identified by downloads
of the atheistic uh of atheists we can
say after 9 11
millions of people say they downloaded
the quran because they're like okay
what's this about
yeah does that mean they automatically
became muslim yeah exactly
i mean first of all 13 million people
might have downloaded the book but it
doesn't mean all of them number one read
it and number two agreed with it
or it could be actually it could be a
vaccination right because
the book has such weak arguments like
michael roos says
um i'm embarrassed to be an atheist
because of this book right this book
makes me embarrassed
and uh you know he makes the conflation
between between metaphysical naturalism
and methodological naturalism there's
fallacies pointed out
by eliot sober by massimo piglucci
yes by michael roos by all these people
right so it could be that muslim
picks up the book and is like okay this
is atheism is about
uh actually it's quite poor and then
they're like i'll never touch atheism
again maybe
he's spreading islamism in the muslim
world absolutely because a lot of the
time when people want to increase their
cultural capital by
learning about new ideas of the west
which is obviously
the um demographic heartland of
the new atheist movement it doesn't it
that
sometimes actually acts as a counter
current yeah
people think oh this if this is what
it's about then we have nothing to do
with it
absolutely but in terms of recent
history i mean we should look at is the
fact that in the 60s and 70s
uh in countries like the countries that
he mentioned iran and egypt
the countries that he mentions in
countries like those you'll find that
there's been a movement from
uh pan arabism or nationalism and
secularism towards
yeah towards islam religiosity
practicing observance of the religion
and that's visible i mean for anyone who
just sees pictures
okay i'm not saying that's the only
yemen afghanistan
all these areas they were secular and
communist in terms of even dress code i
mean
the dress code has shifted completely
look at pictures of egypt in the 1670s
look at pictures of iran
women were probably wearing miniskirts
and these kind of things now
there's a big chunk of the population
yeah in egypt where it's not compulsory
i mean no one's going to get attacked if
did it
that that observed the hijab that
masajid mosques have increased
um i mean even from a from a from an
internet
data point perspective we look at google
trends we look at the
duat or those individuals who call to
islam and their sermons
and their preaching has become extremely
popular especially in the
after 2000 so all the data points
that we can look at and tangibly see
indicate there's been a trajectory move
towards
religiosity rather than the opposite so
he says he's very hopeful
right he's very hopeful of atheism
basically taking over
but i have this question and i don't
know if you thought about this but
uh atheists in general they don't really
have many kids
muslims have a lot of kids and dawkins
entire world view is based on
pondarwanism and the ultimate rationale
according to him in the selfish gene is
the preservation of our genes
reproduction and survival so
could it be that natural selection
darwinism actually causes islamism
because muslims actually have the most
amount of children as you know
and islam is growing faster than actual
the world population is the fastest
growing demographic
so is it possible that that's why islam
is growing and that's why
his hope that atheism is going to
actually prevail is going to fail
because of the theory that he proposed
to believe in
i'll leave that to you because i think
you're that you're the expert on on
issues to do with darwinism but
what i think is that richard dawkins has
delusions of grandeur yeah in his one of
his interviews with the
sun he was asked do you think you're
winning or something that effect and he
says yes we're winning
nothing of the information that we have
from pew research on apostasy which by
the way is methodologically flawed
because they
they in they they interview like 30 or
um iranians
who don't speak english as a first
language and don't represent the bulk of
muslims in america
but even if we look at that and we look
at other data points like the the japan
study on dao and so on we'll find that
really darwinian
arguments which is really the thrust of
his of his book right
as being darwinian the darwinian
mechanism replaces the god's thesis
really that's what he's trying to argue
is not one of the reasons why
people are leaving religion if it is a
reason if if there is a reason
i think in your research you were trying
to in your book uh
you're basically talking about moral
issues yes yeah that being the cause
not not not exactly in terms of if if
there's an intellectual reason which is
not always the case people leaving islam
for example or even christianity
in the case of islam it's usually
morality yeah which is not the exclusive
property of the new atheist argument
well actually they don't have a
um justification for morality in first
place exactly right and that's that's
something else
in the sense that they make these
arguments against religion but so do
other people
many different people who are not new
atheists christians can make arguments
against islamic morality
uh liberal secularists can make
arguments as they
we wouldn't be able to pinpoint whether
their arguments
for islam using morality is the exact or
the reason for the for the switching
do you see what i mean yeah there is
that and you can also sort of argue that
you know he's talking about
atheism taking off in the muslim world
but has it
even really taken off in the western
world because the soviet union
you know they had this massive atheism
project for decades
and when they collapsed people went back
to religion we're finding
new age paganism we're finding these
spiritual movements
rising all across europe rising all
across north america
so it's not even working here why would
it be working in the muslim world well
looking at new atheism
new atheism in particular people like
richard dawkins people like sam harris
and when we look at the the interaction
or the engagement or the numbers
because joe rogan used that term the
metrics the actual internet metrics
with uh for example 10 years ago 15
years ago to now
you'll realize that actually people are
losing interest in their arguments
it's like old arguments that have been
regurgitated
yeah meaning of life and nihilism and
you know these are these people are
irrelevant
yeah i mean richard dawkins is a 78 year
old man
who now has produced a book called is
this your new target now
no no he's not he's not a target because
really and truly
he's an irrelevant person i mean we have
to be honest 78 years old
has just produced a book i'm not going
to even name the title
and if you compare the hits that he has
on that book and
we've used google trends to do so before
and after compared to the god delusion
you realize that it's not even one-fifth
the amount of interest that he got
before
yeah so people are not interested
anymore they've heard what he has to say
some people were convinced who probably
were agnostic in the first place
uh but most people are not and his
broken record arguments are just
becoming a thing of the past they're
gonna go to the dustbin
of uh history really so what about this
joe guy i mean he's just nodding along
like you know one of those puppets and
you know he's also
been trying to promote atheism a lot i
mean do do you see him as an atheist
evangelist as well
i don't know if he's an evangelist i
actually mentioned joe rogan in my book
as a point of comparison to show the
irrelevance of people like richard
dawkins
oh interesting yeah i mentioned him in
some of the the the um
the internet data that i picked up
because he's he's a cultural figure now
and i think he is an influencer and i
think he is extremely relevant
like comparing joe rogan with uh richard
dawkins
is like comparing michael jackson with
uh
i don't know one of these people who
have started a youtube channel smiles
agenda or something
yeah yeah for example yeah exactly
but so the point i'm making is that um
joe rogan though he's an atheist and
for the most part he's just brought
atheists into his podcast he's spoken to
sam harris box and richard dawkins
he he's engaged with ben shapiro
you know softly on judaism he's not
really had someone who
represents the religion an abrahamic
religion
talk to talk them through their
rationale which is why we say it's very
important that
you know uh that he calls someone you
know to
to his podcast who is a muslim and uh
we're always here our service is always
uh
absolutely so as you heard from hijab
for us zahabi we really ask you to make
sure you turn up
again on the joe rogan show yes and do a
good job of representing
islam he did last time martial